hello youtube just Louis in my friends
this is one Jean here the most attacking
third game which I have choose is one of
the biggest attacking while chess player
Michael tell all I can say from this
game is I feel very sorry that Tull
hasn't played much of the Mora gambit
his opponent name was kneeble I tried
very hard to find out the information
regarding kneeble but I haven't find any
picture of kneeble and all I can say is
when the kneeble played this game his
rating was around 2400 this is the one
of the very good small miniature from
the tall and the opening was the Mora
gambit tal started with the movie for
and label responded with the system in
defense c5 and here we will see the
complete acceptance of the Mora gambit
so after d4c cross V 4 C 3 and now D
cross C 3 here at all plays Knight to c3
and you can see the first merit of this
gambit is white has created two semi
open files for his rope and white will
have a very fast and a quick development
so let's see how this game progressed so
for a while we will follow the main line
so needle here played Knight to c6 and
after towel play Knight to f3
he played t6 here tall continues with
the Bishop to c4 so now you can see that
Bishop resigning to the f7 square he
will immediately played a6 so blunting
the diagram of the pressure and now tall
castle on the King side
libel continues with the natural
developing move which is Knight to f6
and after Queen to e2 the idea is very
simple
our Knight wants to come to the defy and
Luke comes to the d1 where they all can
lining up to the d6 so very wisely we
will here play a six to stopping night
or the bishop coming to the v v square
and now tal continues with the usual
line rook to d1 and now you can see the
first merit of the game betting the pawn
rook has been placed against the Queen
so this diagonal is very much dangerous
so nibble immediately get out of the
line so when it will play Queen to c7
but here all played Bishop to f4 so
pressurizing more d6 pawn here never
played Knight to e5 so now the two
pieces are attacking the bishop Tull put
his [ __ ] back to be three and now
enable played Bishop to e7 so he's
eyeing for the King side castle and
completing the development pal completed
it's all peace development with this
move witches look to see one and now you
can see the another dark side of the
Queen to c7 now in the view of night
moving and having a discover attack to
screen level has to forcefully lose the
time and has to play Queen to b8
and here tal played a very easy move
which is night to d4 now first is its
avoiding the exchange and after the
black castle on the kingside it has a
very good idea
starting with this move which is Bishop
to g3 and now you can see the idea is
very simple a white ones to expand with
the move f4 and not only that it will
force night to retrieve and nibble was
so afraid at this point so he
immediately take that night back so he
played night e to d7 and now al placed
f4 anyways and here
Neville played a first mistake of the
game
well I possibly think that he and Abel
should play Knight to c5 which has a
mallet of attacking the bishop and once
the bishop goes back to the c2 it's
although like black has so much passive
pcs but at least black is a pawn up and
black can look forward for at least
holding on this position but the moon
evil play is a big big positional
disaster because mu he played was ePHI
and this is a big big disaster because
you can see there are few drawbacks of
this move first s Knight can slot into
the big juicy FY square where it can
power down to those g7 and e 7
and not only that now you can see by
moving upon further this bishop darrell
has been opened up and you will see some
nasty disaster will be looming on this
diagonal so first of all I'll plate
Knight to f5 very natural so attacking
the bishop
pressurizing more on the d6 and here
again because of this attack knieval has
to forcefully play rook to e8 so
defending the bishop but now you can see
that protection of the f7 Square has
been loosen up and tile exploit this
very very magnificently so first of all
calculate Queen to c4 so now you can see
the board the PCs are attacking the f7
and it's a disgusting position for black
because how the hell he is going to
defend that f7 we will of course after a
long thinking come out with this move
which is defy but after Knight cross
defy he first of all give this check so
Bishop check and after the path the King
in the corner nibble played rook to e6
so trying to defending the rook lift but
there's one big drawback and now you can
see the back rank has become very very
weak and I'll exploit this very very
magnificently
before we go on I give you a few seconds
can you find amazing mu over here okay
the best mode or this position is night
cross app six but instead of that I'll
play the move which looks very very
attractive and in fact giving up the
Queen by Queen cross C Phi of course in
the game opponent does not took the
Queen but let's see what happens if
black took the Queen so if black took
the Queen Knight cross c5 then it leads
to the mate so you can pause the video
and find out the mate the mate start
with this move which is Knight cross f6
check
now if the King goes to the f8 then very
simple is rook check and after rubies
comes in between this leads to the
checkmate and if G cross f6 then very
simple is again the route check and this
leads to the meet as well so of course
that means Queen cannot be captured so
here naval first of all capture this
night so night cross defy here Thal
again played through cross defy and
again you can see the queen has been
offered let's see what happens if black
take the queen if Knight takes the Queen
here then again that leads to the
checkmate so that is not possible so in
the game we will played the last losing
move which is e cross F for now instead
of this red suggested that at six should
be played but even though after at six
we have a simple line like this so light
check and after King to at seven we have
this lovely move which is Queen take C
eight and after a simple line goes like
this rook takes time and Queen takes
Queen and loop takes Queen and rook to
c7 you can see why it is emerge with a
piece up so of course this is not good
as well after II course f4 again I'll
give you a few seconds can you find a
winning continuation which dis meant the
black and that start with this move
which is Knight check now if the King
goes to the h8 then Bishop cross f4 so
it's attacking the Queen and after Queen
287 trying to exchanging the Queen White
will first of all grab this bishop and
after Knight to f8 I can play this
lovely looking move which is up to d8
and black will not survive naga so where
your vyas King to h8 leads to the
disaster so in the game kneeble played
King to a fade but after to cross d7
very amazing threats are looming you can
see first of all this rook is supporting
the plight what is that
White is threatening to give a checkmate
to the black King and the third amazing
thing is it's created discovery to the
black rook so of course neighbor has to
forcefully capture this rogue but after
Bishop cross E six nibble resigned now
very simple is whether
Bishop captures or the pawn captures for
example let's say Bishop captures e6
then after Knight to c6 black we lose
the Queen so very amazing miniature but
at all and this is one of the very
amazing example which shows the tall
ability of attacking
it teach us a lot I hope you enjoy the
attacking miniature of the tall feel
free to comment on my video and I'll
meet you soon bye